[Music]
i'm mark bustos and today i'm going to
go over long hair styling tricks and
tips on men's hair so today we're going
to go over how michael can style his
hair himself at home this is dried
naturally out of the shower and with
minimal product in it right now you're
going to notice that sometimes it's
going to fall into that triangular bell
shape and there's not too much going on
up here which is really where we want to
build a little bit more volume into
there we're going to apply a little bit
of a camellia oil to those ends when
applying this oil you really only want
to use about a drop of it you don't want
to run your fingers through it too much
you really just want to scrunch it in
there and this will help protect the
hair throughout the day and keep it
nourished and moisturized throughout the
entire day next thing we're going to do
is apply a little bit of product into
the root of his hair at the top of his
head my favorite product is this dry
texture spray by orbeck so you want to
just run your fingers right at the scalp
and pull out and lift your lift the hair
right on you're going to spray really
right at the root of the hair you don't
want to hold it too close you want to
hold it about maybe about a foot away
you could already see some of that body
building in through the root at the top
of this head and it's made his hair much
more balanced all around so another look
we can do on michael's hair is to pull
it back depending on the day of the week
and the outfit that he's wearing he may
want to pull it back away from his face
my personal preference is to just comb
it with your fingers and not with an
actual comb you don't want it to look
too done depending on how long the hair
actually is will determine how high or
how low i think it's a pretty cool look
when you wear it up and some of it kind
of falls out gives it more of that
natural weekend look but if you really
want to get it all in there then we can
probably drop his ponytail down to right
about the occipital bone back here i
probably put it around this hair tie
maybe two or three times i'm trying to
just pull it halfway through so it's a
little messier some of this hair will
fall out a little bit a wax or a gel or
a little bit of hairspray even can
really hold that into place and some of
this hair back here will also fall out
but when this falls out it gives it a
pretty cool look too so let's drop this
a little lower see how it works the hair
in the back now reaches but now the hair
on the sides doesn't so depending on
where you wear the bun will determine
what hairs will fall out and as the hair
grows he's going to be able to wear this
bun at different heights in the back of
his head the last thing i want to go
over is the neck hair rather than having
your hair stylist or barber make a nice
clean sharp line we want to keep it a
little bit more natural i like using
this feather razor and it's got these
little notches in it so it's not going
to give it like too much of a clean line
it'll give it a little bit more of a
broken up textured line and the key is
to just keep it as natural as possible
you don't want it to look like you work
too hard kind of looks like you didn't
just get it done it's much cleaner than
it was but at the same time not
perfectly cut into a sharp shape
you